The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: OK.
We have our class.
We've done pretty much
everything up until here,
and we're going to add
this special function here.
So we're implementing
this underscore underscore
eq underscore underscore.
And implementing this
is going to allow us
to compare two types of cars.
So the way I've decided to
compare two types of cars
is I'm saying the
two cars are going
to be equal if they have
the same number of wheels,
they have the same
color, and if they
have the same number of doors.
OK?
So if all of these are
equal, then return true
and else return false.
Inside the actual
program here, I'm
creating one car, four
wheels, two doors.
I'm changing its color to red.
I'm creating another car--
four wheels, two doors.
By default, this new
car, or your car,
is going to have the
color empty string,
because that's how a new
car gets initialized, right?
So between my car and
your car, the difference
is going to be the color.
OK?
So the color is not
going to be the same,
but they have the
same number of wheels
and the same number of doors.
So because I implemented
the equal method in my code,
this does not throw an error.
This lets me proceed.
It compares four with
four, which is good,
two with two, which is good.
And then the colors
don't match, so it's
going to say false,
which most of the guys
are getting it right.